let's say that your school has a
population of 80 students in it maybe
it's not your whole school maybe it's
just your grade
so there's 80 students in your
population and you want to get an
estimate of the average height in your
population and you think it's too hard
for you to go and measure the height of
all 80 students so you decide to find a
simple or take a simple random sample
you think it's reasonable for you to
measure the heights of 30 of these
students and so you what you want to do
is randomly sample
30 of the 80 students
and take their average height and say
well that's probably a that's probably a
pretty good estimate for the population
parameter for the average height of the
entire population
so once you decide to do this you say
well how do i select those 30 students
and how do i select it so that i feel
good that it is actually random and
there's several ways that you could
approach this
one way to do it is
associate
every person in your school with a piece
of paper and put them all in a bowl and
then pick them out so let's do that
so let's say you this is alphabetically
the first person in the school they're
on a slip of paper then the next slip of
paper gets the next person and you're
going to go all the way down so you're
going to have 80 slip pieces of paper
they all should be the same size and
then you throw them all
you throw them all into a bowl of some
kind
and this seems like a very basic way of
doing it but it's actually a pretty
effective way of getting a simple
of getting a simple random sample so
i'll try to draw a little that looks
like a fish bowl or something
all right so that's our bowl
and so all the pieces of paper go in
there
and then you get put a blindfold on
someone and they can't feel what names
are there and so they should pick out
the first 30 without replacing them
because you obviously don't want to pick
the same
you don't want to pick out the same name
twice and those 30 names that you pick
that would be your simple random sample
and then you could measure their heights
to estimate the average height for the
population this would be a completely
legitimate way of doing it
other ways that you could do it if you
have a computer or calculator you could
use a random number generator and the
random functions on on
computer programming languages are on
your calculator they tend to be
something you know some place you'll see
something like a math dot rand rand
short for random you might see something
like random
you might see
might see something like random
without anything passed into it it might
give you a number between 0 and 1 or 1
or 0 and 100 you have to be very careful
on how you use this to make sure that
you have an even chance of picking us of
picking certain numbers but what you
would do in this situation if you had
access to some random number generator
and it could even pick out a random
number between 1 and 80 including 1 and
80 is you would maybe line up all the
students names alphabetically and so the
first student alphabetically assign the
number
and you could just say 1 if you're using
a random number generator but i'll i'll
use two digits for it just because it'll
be useful and consistent and in a little
bit we'll use another technique where
it's going to be nice to be consistent
with our number of digits
and so the next one 0 2 and you go all
the way to
79 and all the way to 80 and then you
use your random number generator to keep
generating numbers from 1 to 80
and as long as though that you don't get
repeats you pick the first 30 to be your
actual random sample
another related technique which is a
little bit more old school but it's
definitely the way that it has been done
in the past and even done now sometimes
is to use a random digit table you still
start with these number associations
with each student in the class and then
you use a randomly generated
list of numbers
and so let's say that's our randomly
generated list of numbers and it keeps
going well beyond this and you start at
the beginning and you say okay we're
interested in getting we're interested
in getting 30
two-digit numbers from 1 to 80 including
1 and 80. so one technique that you
could use is you start it right at the
beginning and you could say all right
this is a randomly generated list of
numbers
so the first number here is 59
is 59 between 1 and 80 sure is as long
as we if this was a 0 1 that would have
worked if this was an 8 0 that would
have worked if this was a 0 0 it
wouldn't have worked if this was an 8 1
it wouldn't have worked but this would
be our this right over here that would
be our first name that we you could
imagine this the same as picking that
first name out of the hat whoever's
associated with number 59
now you would move on you get the next
two digits
the next two digits are 83 they don't
fall into our range from 1 to 80. so
we're not going to use it
then you look at the next two digits so
we get a 5
and a 9. well that fits in our range but
we already picked 59 we already picked
person 59 so we're not going to pick 59
again so we keep moving on
then we get a 37 well that's in our
range we haven't picked that yet
we do that
then
we get a zero zero once again
not in our range i think you see where
this is going 91
not in our range
it's in our range and we haven't picked
it yet so we're gonna pick the 23. i
think you see where this going
we're going to keep going down this list
in the way that i've just described
until we get until we get 30 of these
we've just gotten three we just have to
keep on going and this isn't an
exhaustive list of all of the different
ways that you can get random numbers but
it starts to give you some techniques in
your toolkit and you might say oh well
why don't i just randomly come up with
some numbers in my head and i would i
would really suggest that you don't do
that because humans are famously bad at
being truly random
and you might want to do something like
even use a
something that you think is a random
process but you realize later that it
wasn't as random as you thought so that
once again multiple techniques but these
are some of the i would say best
practices for actually generating a
simple random sample